accused of pushing a Downtown hotel
security office exactly one year ago
today facing a judge on a murder charge
as a news now investigator David Charles
shows us not his first time in court
sir
35 year old Pedro Lozano first tells a
judge he killed how Cortez security
officer Randy Lyons last September
okay he then changed his plea when he
pushed him Randy fell backwards and hid
his head on the concrete
which uh
caused an immediate brain bleed
Elizabeth McDowell was married to lions
for 11 years I went to pick him up from
work and he wasn't coming out he wasn't
coming out he wasn't coming out or I'm
like what's going you know what's going
on police say Lozano shoved lions in the
hotels valet causing him to fall
backward and hit his head doctors told
McDowell Lions would never be the same
and may not survive five months later
she made the difficult decision to take
him off life support and I said and I'm
gonna miss you but this is the best
thing for you and he squeezed my hands
like he understood Lozano was first
charged with battery and as the aduzel
investigators first reported last week
that charge now upgraded to murder the 8
news now investigators researching
Lozano's past finding nearly 50 arrests
in his record many of them for skipping
Court he just looked like I can't
believe that I'm going through this out
outside Court Monday McDowell says she
plans to attend every hearing I don't
hate him
but I can't forgive him right now Lozano
is being held without bail he will be in
court again next week at the Regional
Justice Center on David Jones 8 News Now
that murder charge is enhanced due to
Lion's age and he did plead not guilty
now records showing our investigators
obtain in addition of those 49 arrests
David mentioned police cited Lozano 10
times for other offenses